You're listening to
radiolab, I'm Jad Abumrad,
this is Radiolab and I am Robert Krulwich
and let's begin today with something
deceptively familiar. Fireflies are
something that we all been of those kids,
right? Catching them in the backyard,
putting them in a jar and watching them
glow so we don't tend to think of them
as anything. All that mysterious.
Well, they do one thing very nicely,
which is flash on and off.
That's all fireflies do flash,
but what interests Steve Strogatz,
a mathematician at Cornell University
is that there are places in the world in
not here, but in in Southeast
Asia, in Malaysia or Thailand,
where fireflies don't just flash
randomly like we're used to.
They somehow flashed together.
There are enormous congregations of
fireflies along riverbanks. How many,
it could be tens of thousands,
tree after tree extending for
literally miles along the rivers,
all flashing in sync like a Christmas
tree rows and rows of Christmas trees all
wired together going off and it's one
of the most hypnotic and spellbinding
spectacles in nature because you have
to keep in mind it is absolutely silent.
I can picture it. There's
a riverbank in Thailand,
in the remote part of the jungle. You're
in a canoe slipping down the river.
There's no sound of anything,
maybe the occasional, you know,
exotic jungle bird or something and
you're looking and you just see route
with thousands of Mites on
and then off, all in sync.
[inaudible]
imagine all the cheese as far as you
can see are all brilliantly lit and then
totally dark, brilliantly
lit, total darkness,
all of them in sync. Yeah, and no
Wessler had ever seen this site.
There was folklore, there's
the stories about it,
but nobody had gone in and
photographed and captured samples.
Well not until 1965 and this was
done by John Bark. John Bark,
the see one of the great
researchers or his other records.
I'm 92 buck and his wife Elizabeth,
mass buck went to Thailand and
captured bags full of mail.
Firefly catched. We checked
them, shaking the branches,
firefly rained out and brought them back
to their hotel room and we turned off
the lights.
We turned them loose and saw that the
fireflies flittered around on the walls
and ceiling flew back and
forth flashing random.
He Elizabeth layer on the floor
of the room. I was just tired.
John stayed away and he was the one who
saw within a few minutes little groups
duos and trios formed and after a while
fourth one would join in a closer,
closer together. Then finally
they were synchronized.
The whole room was blinking in perfect
harmony. He was excited. The next they
told me outlet.
20 years later John Buck is still asking
this question, Oh what is going on?
Because no one knows. There are literally
10 theories. What seems to be clear,
so Steve is there is no one
firefly that makes it all happen.
It just happens on its own order,
materializes out of nothing and that
hasn't puzzled how can order come out of
out of disorder and this is what the
creation has loved to talk about and it's
because they don't understand and
neither do we this, this is the big,
big mystery of science.
I think bigger than plaque holes are
bigger than super strings. I mean,
science has had hundreds of years of
success since the time of Galileo and
Newton from reductionism, from
looking at the smallest parts,
whether they're jeans or
Adam's, whatever. That's great.
We need to understand the
individuals, but that's not enough.
Obviously we're not just talking about
fireflies anymore. Today on Radiolab,
we will do as Steve Urges and step away
from the individual to find mystery,
beauty and order in the
group, not fireflies.
They are groups of city dwellers. Groups
have Internet, surfers, stock traders,
even the group of neurons
that are inside your head.
This is a science called
emergence. So let's begin.
In the beginning, God created
heaven and earth. That's the King
James Bible. That's how it starts.
The ultimate expression of the boss,
God telling everything else what to
be, how to be. It's a top down kind of
what about midway through the
Bible contains another passage,
more of a bottom up
thing from King Solomon,
the wisest of the kings where
he says, look to the ants.
Consider her ways and be wise. Yes.
So we start in California,
the office of an ant
expert. I'm Deborah Gordon,
professor of biology at Stanford.
Hi Deborah Gordon has been
studying ants for over two decades.
It's because such mindless individuals
collectively can do so much that I'm
interested in.
His might say she's the reigning ant
Queen as long as you bring up the reigning
part. When we went there
I thought, well what's,
she has a lot of answers but I wanted to
see what the Boston looked like so she
led us to our lab and going
into the secret and place
where we found to our disappointment that
she keeps the ants and big Tupperware
container.
This is the foraging area of a colony
that's stuck living in the lab instead of
out in the desert where it would probably
rather be and plastic box with plastic
around it and little bits of sand on it.
That's right and so I'm
going to take off the top.
Maybe we can see the queen better, but
like this, I've never seen it before.
When I'm looking for the clean
one. What am I looking for?
Just the ant and the center of the
biggest crunch of other hand. Well,
usually there are a lot
of other ants around her.
She doesn't look much
different, but she's bigger.
Does the ants know that she's special?
I think the ants know
that she's the queen.
Okay,
and does it, what does that mean? Well,
the queen in the way we
think about clicks. Yeah.
I mean that they know grows mommy
or not even? I don't think so. No.
Uh,
I don't think they know anybody. Has
Anybody. And remember she's not in charge.
She's not telling anybody what to do.
Wait a second. Wait a second. Yeah.
This is different than
I had actually imagined.
I thought that Queens gave command.
Like, you know an Alice in wonderland.
Bob, what? Bare hands kind of thing,
da. She says no, she's just a big hand
that lays the eggs. That's it. That's it.
Every year there's a meeting flight
and all of the colonies send out their
virgin queens who have wings and nails
who also have wings and they all go to
one place and they gather and they meet
and the newly mated queens fly off and
start new colonies. That's how it
starts. Queen scanner make babies,
but that's all
they do. They're just
the colonies, ovaries.
They don't sit on a throne and decree
anything nor are their generals or even
bosses. The colony somehow
gets by without any of that,
which is especially hard to believe
when you watch these ants. Ooh,
tell us what's happening here. This
is [inaudible] carrying a dead hat.
I remember there was this one little EDBD
and carrying a big fat dead and on her
back and look at this.
She seems to be gradually,
although with some difficulty
living twice my elbow.
Then she dropped it. Then she picked
it up again and she dropped it.
You that up again. Now she's
turning in the other direction.
All the while carrying this heavy corpse.
She made like it back and forth like
that for hours sometimes can leave some
objects we'll get in there that they
can't all carry and they can spend months
tagging it one way and
tagging it the other way.
Month tugging back and forth on either
side of one seed. It wasn't a seed,
it was a little twig. One of them is
thinking this way and I was thinking, oh,
this way, going this way, this way.
And that's all that's going on. Well,
I don't know what they're thinking.
Right. I know. I know that a fan,
one of them is pulling one way because
the stick feels like something that needs
to be pulled and the
other also feels right.
The stick needs to be
pulled and they just pull.
It must be frustrating watching
these mindless exchanges. It is.
It can be very frustrating. I don't
have very much empathy for apps.
They're so, um, the
more you watch the ants,
the more weird it seems, the
way they never get discouraged.
They don't care if they do something well.
Um, it's very alien. I
think she hates them.
Not really because here's the thing.
You can make an argument that,
so the most successful
species on the planet,
they thrive in places that are
too hot for us to dry for us.
Even too cold for us. They
outnumber us by a factor,
many thousand in pure evolutionary
math terms. They're winning,
which intrigues her
and also forces you to think
about them differently.
I think about what the colony is doing
and then I tried to think how it would
work. If you do it like that,
she says answer actually amazing,
but you have to ignore the
individual individually.
They're totally incompetent and
keep your focus big as colonies.
They do great things. It's
kind of a constant whiplash,
zoom in stupid two and spoil a
twig back and forth for months.
You zoom out smart. I'm
impressed that it works at all.
It's somewhere between the zooming in
and zooming out and bizarre intelligence
appears almost like a phantom.
I think the most intelligent thing I've
ever seen harvester ants do is to build
a little turret around
the opening of the nest,
just as the summer monsoons are gathering
and then when it rains and floods,
it's raised up so that
the water doesn't go in.
So when I see the first few ads coming
out with their little twigs and I look up
in the sky and I see a few clouds in
the distance and I realized that there's
some link between the change in the
barometric pressure or something,
and it really is a very tidy and
effective little construction.
And what else do ans do? Well, let
me just count them for you. Shall I?
Aunts farm, they have livestock,
aunts make garden pants,
organize wars, have genitals and
soldiers and things take slaves.
There's the young man's tunnel involved.
Incredibly good and
sophisticated climate control.
You can start from two opposite directions
and meet precisely midway answer
engineered hats,
orchestrate massive public work
projects that puts FTRs new deal.
I'm talking about Tennessee Valley
Authority from your homes. Hey,
that's as nothing compared
to what hands could do.
Alright.
Hello, which raises the question
at the center of this program,
which is how do so many very stupid
creatures with no boss add up to be so
smart?
The scientist who first really tackled
this idea with some success in the mid
1950s was e o Wilson from
Harvard University because
he made one of the great
discoveries in all the
science of communication.
Certainly we know that creatures
make noises to each other,
sometimes touch each other,
but he figured out pheromones.
Pheromones are the key to understand the
communication of the vast majority of
animals species. We didn't know
it then. It's a neat story.
He told me that a few years back up
at 92nd street y in New York City.
One day I shut out, I was
culturing fire ranch then in the
laboratory at Harvard and I said,
I'm going to get to the bottom of this.
And the way I did it was to, uh,
dissect these tiny, tiny, it's very
difficult to do, but I just checked them.
And under magnification I can
see that it's sticking out,
sting and dragging the Stinger.
Something's coming out of that sting.
Kind of like a fountain pen or
something's too bit like that. Yeah. Yeah.
So a I proceed to, um, believe me, folks,
this was the way science because
I mean it really is simple minded.
It's only later when you're doing
the technical paper, you know,
when you're producing the mathematical
models and that it looks tough.
It's really, this is the way
you're thinking when you're
doing shots. So I said,
I'm going to find out what
the organs are inside this.
And so what I did was
to do anatomy and then,
uh, you know,
just the sect that I knew approximately
what the different glands were in
showing you snipped off the part where
the glands were you suited or while you
just distract open. Oh, you
opened it. Right. You know, and,
and just the way you would any animal
alerts exceedingly difficult when it's
about the size of greater salt.
That's the tough part. But anyway,
I took out the various organs one after
the other and I made a preparation and I
made an artificial trail,
smeared out one Oregon
after another no effect. Oh,
so their aunts over here and you're
drawing lines, right? Oh, gut stuff.
I guess basically what it is,
Yo Justin or different organs.
I've watched each one in churn and then
smeared it out and finally I came to a
little finger shaped organ,
which we didn't know.
The function of it is just a tiny little
thing talk down there and I mirrored
that out and incredible. It wasn't,
I didn't have to tell
them to follow that trail.
They exploded out of the nest
running along that thing.
I started playing around with this. It
was sure effective for demonstrations.
I would write my name,
a column of 102 hundred three a hundred
ads would come pouring out back and
forth and they'd actually
write my name and I am
so that was the first clue. Smell.
Ants may not take orders from above,
but they can exchange information. See
this one with the abdomen bent under?
Yeah. That one is somehow reacted to us.
Oh really strange smells that we're
making that could Deborah Gordon's lab.
As we watch the colony,
one of the aunts even stopped
what it was doing to smell us.
When they wave their antennae in the air,
they're looking around because their
antennae or their periscopes sounds simple
enough. Ants follow scent
trails sorta like dogs.
But if you stare at them long enough,
you will see that when these
ants get together, lots of them,
these simple sniffing talents,
they have add up to solve
pretty amazing problems.
Here's a forage or coming back. What's
it in her mouth? It's a seed like this.
Suppose there are a bunch of forged your
ANZ in one part of town and something
good to eat in another part of
town. Like if there's a picnic,
how does the colony get
more ants to your picnic?
They're blind and virtually
brainless. So how do they do it?
That's the question.
How they do it. Hello,
I'm ABCDF G with that question in mind.
We visited up Princeton biologist,
Ian Kusan. This one
here? Yeah. What is this?
Now you pops open his laptop to
show us a beautiful map he's made.
So here on the on the screen you can see
the individual paths coded by color and
ant map.
It's as if you gave a few hundred aunts
a paintbrush and then let them wander
over on canvas.
On the computer has software which
tracks the motion of each of these
individuals. The resulting picture
is vintage Jackson Pollock,
lots and lots and lots of layers of
squiggly lines so you can put the food in
here. For example,
I've got droplets of sugar water here
that the ans love the feed on the end
points to a splotch of white
in the upper right hand corner.
Then flips in the next image
jumping forward in time.
What what I've actually shown with this
is that the ants have begun forming a
chemical trail and you can actually
show how they've laid a trail to this,
this, this good food source.
This is the type of image that makes
you want to stare at static on your TV
screen and look for patterns.
It's downright eerie.
One minute the screen is a mass chaos
of squiggles overlapping no patterns at
all.
The next is if by magic the squiggles
of snap together to form a vein leading
directly to the sugar.
It happens every time.
And what's weirder says Ian
is every time it happens,
it happens by accident error. Really.
I mean this is really what we're talking
about is these ants probably just made
a mistake. Error is
architecture. Imagine 500 answer,
exploring a space number 411 finds the
sugar completely by accident except it's
not an accident because the aunt
has left a sent trail in there.
500 other answers, surely one other will
come along and make the same mistake.
Suddenly you've got two chemical
trails on top of each other,
double e hot tracking a third
which makes the trail triple hot,
attracting five more,
which makes it [inaudible] hot and soon
what you've got as a blazing pheromone
highway of bumper to bumper and
[inaudible]
none. I'm like mid town during rush hour.
when I first saw the ants, uh, in person,
one of the first thoughts I had was
this looks like a small little city.
Steven Johnson noticed this connection
and wrote about it in a book called
emergence. The connected lives of
ants, brains, cities and software.
A lot of what the ants do is positive
feedback loops where they lay down a kind
of pheromone chemical signal to recruit
other ants to do something that they're
working on and those ants lay
down more of the same signal can.
So very quickly you can get a whole bunch
of ants working on a single problem.
That's the similar effect that you get
in a way that city neighborhoods form
accidents that always happen.
That is how ants find food and he
says how cities find their shape.
It gets to what I said
was called the swirl
that comes with this
gun. When you're walking down the
sidewalk going from point x to point y,
you're going from subway
back to your house
and you pass by completely
accidentally point Z,
which is a new boutique
or a new restaurant,
something that catches
your eye and you swerve.
You see this thing you've never
seen before and you're like, hey,
I want to check that out.
The whole business in a sense of sidewalks
and thriving urban centers revolves
around the idea that somebody coming to
see boutique a is going to be swerving
into Boutique B or Boutique c just because
they're near each other and because
they're kind of window shopping.
What a neat idea. Yeah. Right?
You wake up thinking, well,
here's what I'm going to do in the city.
I'm going to walk my daughter to school.
I'm going to go to the new standard
by a paper, and then on your way,
something that you didn't expect,
something new catches your eye.
Begonias I will always want that. And
Sally, that's the big Onia she wants,
right? So you swerve, which
begins as an accident,
but all these kind of local unplanned
decisions all add up into this larger
macro unit that does have a distinct
personality and that crucially can
last for hundreds of years,
which does make you wonder because
the personalities of cities,
we know about that.
You know how come there are distinct
neighborhoods for rich people?
There are neighborhoods in
some cities for artists, slums.
Consider a 28th street in [inaudible]
today in the flower market
we have hydrangeas and uh,
some flowers from Florida. How many
flowers, doors are on this block?
If I had to guess, I'd probably say about
25 there are flower stores all around.
It's like a Walmart for flowers in a week.
How did this begin?
Let's propose that someone for some reason
came here and set up the flower shop,
which picked up a few customers.
So then a second flower merchant.
Since he's getting the traffic,
maybe if I opened a store,
like the head of he is on the block,
maybe I'll be able to pull some people
away from him having swerve into my
store. Location, location, location,
and let's say that gets more traffic.
You've got to be with the traffic,
so then you get the third store.
That works too. You could sell pencils
that look like ducks and nothing else,
and if you're writing them all
time square, you know what?
You'll probably make money. That's
the key. Traffic is everything.
Once a neighborhood becomes the place
for duck shape pencils or the place for
flowers, what began as an accident
then becomes a neighborhood. So much.
So if I blindfolded a flower salesman
and dropped him onto a hundred blocks,
would he know which one was 28th
street? Oh, absolutely. Yes. Shit.
Why have I just died now my street
man, I just smelled the flower.
Highest Sense. You just build the highest
as soon as you walk in there. I mean,
of course I, I've, ah, it's all under
the heading. Trucks. Rephrase, screaming,
yelling. I mean please.
It's a quasi mystical concept.
I really do think of it when you think
about a neighborhood in a great city,
whether it's New York and the West village
or Paris in the Latin quarter of the
middle class, you know, ask the question
like, who created this neighborhood,
right? Who created the things
we love about this neighborhood?
Who creates that kind of life force?
And the answer is everybody
and nobody at the same time.
Okay. [inaudible]
so that brings us again to the
central mystery of this hour.
We're studying here. The
science of emergence,
which asks where does
organization come from?
How do you get a neighborhood,
a district or a city?
How do you get the complexity of an ant
colony if there's no leader and everyone
in town is stupid? Steve,
Steve Johnson proposes that a city is
the emergent quality of the swerve to
series of accidents, you know
is always going to happen.
You multiply the swerves,
you get a neighborhood.
Debra Gordon is arguing that if you look
very closely at the aunts and you watch
them smelling and you
multiply their smells,
then you get the complexity of an
IED colony but buried in the system.
Both of them say is a rule, a sense
of direction, but how do you see that?
That's the wrong question and
that's what's so uncomfortable.
The instructions aren't anywhere.
The instructions come out of the way
that the colony lives and behaves.
That's hard. It is hard. If
you had one aunt on its own,
you couldn't take it apart and find the
substance that would make it behave in a
certain way. Did you see how hard
that is? Yes. I want to know.
So when you asked her to find the rule,
yeah. So when you did any individually,
you see it when all the ants get
together, but where is it? Well,
where is the thought in your
brain? Is it in a neuron?
Does each neuron have a
little piece of the thought?
If you took your neuron out
and lay it on the table,
could you see the little tiny bit of
the thought that's in that neuron? No,
it's not in the neuron. It's in the way
the neurons interact with each other.
[inaudible]
think about a syrup painting.
That one where they're all on the banks
of the Cen River. Yep. You're the one,
if you look at it up close,
all you see is dots, right?
You pull back and the picture emerges
with all the ladies in their parents'
cells. But the question
with these systems,
the big question is whether there is
a syrup to make the dots, the paint,
the picture, or if somehow the
painting just materializes on its own.
Uh, well, you know, that I have an
opinion about this, but it's not a,
it's not a sciencey opinion. Uh,
I think it's not just fascinating that
there are these hidden patterns and
hidden rules.
I think it's just going
to change the whole tone.
I think it's kind of holy and I don't
have to go scientific evidence because
there's no science behind
this. It's just an instinct.
I think when you look at the way ants
work or the way it's shot painting images
before your eyes, you're
looking at an author,
see, see, when you say that, all the
air just gets let out of the balloon.
For me, it's like the magic is gone. We
really can. I think so. Let's
see what you're left with.
Then everything that you see when you
wake up in the morning is beautiful and we
all agree that it's beautiful.
Is Empty of purpose.
Is that okay with you? Yeah.
In a way it makes it even more
mysterious to be alive in any case,
author or not.
There's really good reason why
these systems would not centralize,
put all their eggs into one basket,
one supreme being. Because if they did,
they'd be vulnerable. Case in point,
this story from producer
Laura Star Chesky,
I'll walk you over toward
the beehives, not about ants.
So we're sort of in their flight zone,
but don't worry bees and we'll
just see if we have any luck here.
She met up recently with a
beekeeper named John Clayton.
It's always hit and miss trying
to find a queen, that's for sure.
She's right there. Get off me. Thank you.
One of the things that beekeepers really
like to do is raise their own queens.
All you need to do is take a frame out
of an existing hive that has egg cells on
it and a bunch of worker bees and put it
in its very own box and they'll realize
that they don't have a queen and they'll
pull an egg or pull larva and start
feeding it.
The Royal Jelly make the peanut shape
Queen Cell and 16 days later you got a
brand new queen. Well, one time I uh,
I made a brand new,
Kwame was my first queen.
I was probably 17 years old at the time
and I had it out on my back porch and I
knew it come day three,
she goes out to mate.
So I'm sitting there and here it sure
enough comes to queen out the entrance and
she flies off and she takes off and,
and I'm watching and I'm watching the
whole meeting process take place and it
takes place in flight.
She made a inflight with about 10
drones and the drones die after mating.
They come crash into the ground dying
and the queen goes back to the hive.
And while she started coming back to the
hive and then I realized I had a piece
of sticky fly tape hanging up on the
back porch and she flew right into it and
there's my queen all stuck to
the fly tape like this, you know,
I said there's my first queen and I
killed the poor thing cause there was
nothing I could do to save it.
Yeah, it was just a horrible story.
So it's one of those things you
learn from experience, you know,
but it was a sad moment because
they a queens a special thing.
Just gonna chat there.
Thanks to producer Laura Starecheski
and beekeeper, John Clayton
coming up the science of how a trillion
leaderless neurons in your head come
together and music fashion to sing the
song of the thought you are thinking
right now, which if you're a caffeine
addict like me, just might be
[inaudible].
I'm Janet, I'm Ron Robert Krulwich
and I will continue in a moment.
All right, now your new assignments are,
who's going to be read anyway?
Who's going
to be round?
Hi,
this is Steve Stroke at radio lab is
funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan
Foundation and the National
Science Foundation.
Radiolab is produced by Wny C and
distributed by MPR and this message,
this is Radiolab. I'm chat up with rod
here with Robert Krulwich. Say Hello.
Thank you.
This hour we're trying on a way of looking
at the world that has nothing to do
with presidents or queens or mayors and
everything to do with ants and sciences
is an idea called emergence. How many,
many stupid things can add up to something
very smart like a colony or in our
case a city. Now speaking of us,
it is often and was often assumed
that leaderless snus is a bad thing,
a very dangerous thing.
And this was especially the
case in the late 19th century,
early 20th which is our next stop.
It was a time when throughout Europe
hostile irrational crowds were everywhere
in the streets.
You really see this enormous backlash
in large part in reaction to the rise of
democracy. This is James
Scher Wiki author of the book,
the wisdom of crowds and he's talking
about the people on the other end of the
riots, the intellectual elite.
Look at people like Thomas Carlisle
who started the Bon of France.
Nicha obviously for all these people,
crowds were really the epitome
of irrationality and stupidity
[inaudible]
but that was about to change and he tells
this story of a guy named Sir Francis
Galton. Yeah, I'm sure Francis Gordon,
who is this sort of famous British
scientist and is actually a most famous
cause. He was the founder of what we now
know as eugenics. Oh, is that so, yeah.
He's sort of a notorious elitist and a,
what's funny is that this is a story
about him finding the opposite of,
of his basic assumptions.
A to be true story goes on a nice
fall day in 1906 Sir Francis Galton,
a guy who truly believed that only the
better classes should be allowed to vote
rule or even have children. He decides
to spend the day in the country.
Ladies and gentlemen, step right this way.
[inaudible] county fair
right over here. Now,
this is going to be quite an
experience for you young man.
The thing that caught Golden's attention
that day was a competition involving
and ox.
I mean, they're, they're on this way.
You might want to avoid that unfortunate
plot right there. I didn't like. Yeah.
Know. What I want you to do, please,
is I want you to examine this very
fat ox [inaudible] touch the OP.
What we do is we look at the
ox and we weigh it in our mind.
[inaudible] you know, the group
was, was was a really diverse crowd.
Family members, local merchants,
most of whom were not experts at
all in Wayne Oxen, young lady.
You know how to weigh a package, don't you
think you can weigh a package? Then you
can weigh an ox. Here's how you do it.
You take a, I don't know,
a couple of packages and put
them in your head and say, well,
this ox seems to be about 70 packages
to multiply the weight of a package by
side.
They paid six pants and
they would, you know,
make their guests in the people that
had the best guesses, woodwind prizes,
large cash prize.
So quite a few people. Yes,
there's something like 800 people close
to 800 and while none of those 800 or so
people guessed the exact weight of the
ox prizes were awarded, people went home.
But the ever inquisitive, Sir Francis
Hung around after the contest was over.
Excuse me, golden went up
to the organizers. Wow.
Would you mind [inaudible] who said,
can I have the guesses if I take
possession of all 787 ticket?
You know the slips they had written the
guesses on. Oh, right. You can have in,
I suppose I don't see anything
wrong with that, but why?
Because I'm wondering something
Caesar. Francis figured these
common people wouldn't have a clue.
Most of them were overwhelmingly
uninformed and an expert
in bovine matters and
he just assumed that if you added up a
lot of uninformed on expert individual
opinions, you'd get a very
uninformed, an expert group opinion.
That's what he was counting on.
One of the things he did was he
just calculated the average gap.
That is the mid point, the me of all the
guesses. He figured they'd be way off,
but when he did that,
it turned out that collectively the
citizens of Plymouth said the ox weighed
1,187 pounds,
101,187 pounds, hope a cure, which was
astonishingly close.
A oxys actual weight was 1,188 pounds.
They're a pound off.
They were basically perfect and they
were actually better than any single
individual in the group.
Colton was stunned.
This went against everything
he knew to be true,
but you have to give him credit because
he didn't publish the results. He was,
you know, curious enough to
acknowledge possibilities
that this experience that
uh, they've gotten had.
We went up to a lot of dumb people and
collectively they somehow were smarter as
a group than any one of them.
[inaudible] is an experience that has
been experimentally tested over and over
and over. So it, liberal arts
colleges all over the United States,
professional liberal arts college because
that's where these kinds of things
happen. A science professor never
happens. A vocational school is just that.
It's, I'm being a Snob at schools
everywhere. A science professor,
a psychology professor usually puts a
bowl of jelly beans in front of the room
and says, how many people here can you
just guess the number of Jellybeans?
And over and over and over again. No
one in the room gets the exact number,
but everyone in the room
at the mean comes closest.
Somehow the group is smarter than
even the smartest kids in the class.
And according to James or Wiki,
this is not just a history lesson,
but that it actually is,
is something you can see at work and a
lot of other places and can be used to
solve much more complex problems,
much more complex problems. Well,
let's just take one example.
The Internet,
if you go back and read a lot of the
discussion on the Internet from 1995 to
1998 it was totally dominated by people
saying, yeah, the Internet's neat,
but you can never find anything and
nobody says that anymore. I mean,
it's just a problem that Google just
completely solved. It's an amazing thing.
Just a few members, Steven Johnson,
author of the Book Emergence,
and here I argues that
exact same mysterious crowds
smarts that was president of
the ox guessing contest is what allowed
Google to become such a great search
engine almost overnight. So
what Google decided wanted
to do was to solve the
problem of organizing the web
in a bottom up rather than
a top down approach.
And what Google said was anytime
somebody decides to link to a page,
we're going to count that as a vote,
as a positive endorsement of the page
that they're linking to. So this,
this is like a little democracy. So
it's a little democracy. Exactly.
And so what they said is pages that have
a lot of people pointing to them are
going to be more highly valued in the
Google kind of system or algorithm than
pages and nobody points to. So
if some guy has a blog, which,
which is really great and, and a
ton of other people linked to him,
he gets in essence what you're saying,
a lot of votes. He wins the election,
he went to votes and they
added a second layer to it,
which is that when that guy
points to somebody else,
his link is more valuable than your
average Schmoe's because a lot of people
point to him. So he has
more kind of googled juice.
When you think about the way that city
neighborhoods form, you ask the question,
where does city neighborhoods come
from? And the answer is, you know,
well everybody and nobody at the
same time as kind of creating this.
When you search for something on
Google and you get a list of results,
that is often really, really good
because Google gives these great results.
Ask Yourself, who
decided that this result?
Here is number one in this
result is number two. Well,
the answer is everybody and nobody.
It's nobody on staff at Google.
You know Google isn't deciding
that this is the premier site for.
If you search for Steven Johnson
and this is the second best site,
if you searched for Steven Johnson,
collectively all the people who are
offering documents on the web have decided
that this is the best site by
choosing to link or not link.
Basically the intelligence of Google
is an emergent property of all of these
local decisions to link,
none of which were made until recently
with the intent of influencing Google.
Now what's happened recently
is that people have started
to try and trick it was
my next question to me. You can
manipulate, you can manipulate it,
so I actually have this experience.
This is one of the most annoying things
it's happened to me in the last year and
it's ironic because it comes out of
precisely the thing that I celebrated and
championed and I've been an advocate
for him for the last five years. Um,
I have a website that a lot of people
link to and thus I have a disproportionate
power over Google here. When I point
something, they will jump up in a,
yeah. Have you seen this in
practical tools? Absolutely. Well,
one way you can tell is
that for a stretch of time,
if you searched Google for Stephen,
I was the number one result.
Just Steven just evolved the Stevens
in the middle of the Stevenson,
the world of the Steven
Spielberg's is Stephen Kings.
I was the number one Stephen,
and obviously on some level Google is
wrong in thinking that I have the number
one Stephen in the world. I mean, I
like to think very highly of myself,
but I'm not the most important
Stephen in the world,
but it's because I have a website that a
lot of other bloggers and people in the
kind of Internet community point to.
Well maybe you are number nine, Steve.
According to Google, I'm no longer Irish.
I've dropped to number five or six,
which has been a great tragedy in my life.
Who's number one now? Uh, I think it,
last I looked at was this, I
think he's a country music star.
Like Steven Curtis Chapman. Yeah,
I'm still up there. So you know,
it's all right. But anyway,
so because I have this power
with Google on my website,
there's an open comment area where
anybody can come and post a thought in
response to something that I had posted.
And about a year ago people
started posting these random
kind of nonsense posts
that would have a link in at
pointing off to some, you know,
free Viagra site or to a porn site or
to, you know, kind of get a mortgage,
you know? So it was a coattails
thing. This guy's good.
So I'm going to get on his coattails.
Exactly, and initially I was like, look,
I don't have that many people coming here
that it makes sense to advertise in my
comments area,
but I finally realized that they weren't
trying to attract the people who were
hanging out at my site. They
were trying to attract Google.
They were talking purely to Google's
automated kind of searching.
They were saying, look,
Google will see this as an endorsement
from Steven Johnson pointing to this free
gambling site and see this is what
separates us from the ants right here,
is that we're aware that
this is a colon. Yes,
you can step out and play
the system because people
are smart and they have this
ability to kind of reflect on this
system that they're a part of.
We're able to advance faster, but
you also have cheats and spoilers.
We'll destroy the system.
And I eventually, you know,
this is this tragic thing,
but I had to,
I had basically to shut down these
conversation areas that I had on my site
because because he spent,
I would get literally a hundred of these
spam posts in a day and a lot of them
were really obscene. So
it was like, you know,
my mother would come to my side
and be like, what are you doing?
What is going on?
Steven Johnson is the author of the book
emergence as well as mind wide open and
he's working on a new one,
which will be out soon about
how everything that's bad
for you is actually good
for you. So it is no surprise
that he is currently number four,
Steven on Google binds, Steven Spielberg,
Steven Soderbergh, Stephen King,
but ahead of this guy
to the
Massey and die.
This is Steven Curtis
Chapman. So from a crowd,
even a pretty dumb crowd
can emerge magically.
Beautiful complexity.
And this after all was the great insight
of Adam Smith wealth of nations seven
no, you don't have to sell me. In 1776
he wrote a book in which you propose
that there's an invisible hand when
everybody wants to buy something and
everybody else wants to sell something.
Somehow it all comes together
in a perfect balance.
Down 30 to 40 speaking of
which, my name's Ben Rubin.
I'm a sound artist in New York City,
and what you're about to hear is
a piece I made called open outcry.
We'll hear an excerpt.
Silver 44 78
crude oil, 30 53 silver, silver
[inaudible] nine zero zero
[inaudible] [inaudible]
sometimes I say to people, did you
hear rebidding? And I know if they say,
I didn't hear you,
I know they're not telling me the truth
because people always hear my voice.
It's, it's unique and it's a strong
voice too. If I'm selling October's,
you know, you don't say, you say
ark and you don't say the full hand.
I'll just say like AUC at 10
so I'd just yell at, I get 10
oh it's 75 play by play
five so 25 75 bit at 78
seven bedrock seven beds, 25
84 45
by a hundred
yeah. Listen to one person at a time.
You're hearing everybody
speak at the same time.
It's like going to a symphony and
hearing every piece of the orchestra,
but yet hearing the music at the
same time. And in the midst of that,
you may observe, for instance,
a broker that you've
traded with for years.
You notice face looks
like when he's laughing,
you know what his face looks like when
he's upset about something at home and
suddenly he's got a nervous look. You
can tell when somebody's just bluffing.
When somebody is not bluffing in this.
These are all skills that are, you know,
learned over time. It's really
an internal gut feeling.
And as far as just seeing the
expression on someone's face,
the way that somebody breathing,
the way that somebody is
leaning on someone else.
I always knew when the guy behind me had
a real order. Cause when he had a big,
big order,
he used to take my shoulder and shove
it to the ground trying to hold himself.
He's too bad. These too
too. So 50 decent toe
[inaudible] he's too big. Nobody
and a half. No, me. Five and a half,
five
[inaudible] [inaudible]
orange juice now up and down
gasoline,
natural
gas.
[inaudible]
it takes the sound artists,
Ben Ruben and the next big thing
for letting us borrow that piece.
Coming up the story of the biggest
search and possibly discovery since the
double helix. And it
involves the same guy.
I'm Jad Abumrad Robert Krulwich
and I will continue in a minute.
You're listening to radio
lab. Keep listening. Okay.
Hey everyone, this is Matt in St Louis.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
this is Radiolab. I'm Jab.
I'm rod here with rubber crow,
which this hour we're looking
at the science of emergence.
How the world often seems to organize
itself into being without an obvious plan
or a leader. Well, think about an ant
colony or termites, right? I mean,
they're trying to build a nest
mathematician, Steve Strogatz.
And if you look at any individual termite,
it's just moving along and its antennas
or wiggling and it's smelling fair
amounts and it has no
idea what it's doing.
It doesn't know it's trying to build an s,
it's just responding to whatever little
chemical is right in front of its nose.
And yet out of this, you see a
coordinated group that looks like it's,
you know, everybody
knows what they're doing,
but in fact nobody knows what they're
doing. And the same thing with your brain.
No cell in your 100 billion cells
in your brain is having a thought.
But together they are together.
They're falling in love or are wanting
to write music. So who's in there?
Do we have any idea why this
happens or how, I guess that's,
that's the question.
[inaudible]
and it's a really fascinating question
when you really kind of pause to think
about it. For example, look, I have here,
you see this as my, my cup of coffee.
Um, I'm looking at it and you
know, it's a cup of coffee,
but how does my brain know
that this is a cup of coffee?
It's something that's uh,
in a way it's hard to even understand
what the question is because this comes so
naturally to us, right?
We just look at something and we have
this integrated perception of a cup of
coffee.
Like what's the big mystery? I
hear you did use all of her sacs.
So you had him on the show recently.
He would probably be able to talk to you
in an interesting way about people for
whom this does not come easily.
There is a famous case which was
reported in Germany of a, uh,
a woman who had lost motion perception.
And there's a very nice description,
for example, of her difficulty, Pauling
t till that Oliver, now this woman,
she takes the teapot and she starts to
pour and suddenly the image just freezes.
She would have stills
lasting about 15 seconds.
She would see a glacio.
She used that term at glacio
fluid coming from the teapot.
Her brain was seeing
something, not moving,
but then her feet were getting, and
then suddenly there was a puddle.
They were getting wet and
indeed crossing a vote.
It was impossible for this
woman in Germany. Dangerous.
And so it's those people who help us
realize the miracle of perception, right?
That the, to see the world as
a coherent thing is a miracle.
[inaudible]
should we hit them at the same time? No.
You can think of yourself as fireflies
and you're out buzzing separate trees.
Okay, so back to your miracle
of the Coffee Cup. So yes,
for those of us who are healthy,
we do this all the time.
The question however remains
how I have trillions.
And trillions of neurons
in my head firing randomly.
Every neuron that you're hearing
here, just going a little, no,
we can live on electrical thing
and the question is how does this,
which seems so rampantly
disorganized, how does it resolve
the [inaudible] Cup of coffee?
Yeah, good question. Now,
a few years ago,
a number of neurologists trying to figure
out how the idea of coffee comes to be
came upon a kind of musical analogy
that I'm bringing, creating a thought,
creating, say a cup of coffee
is kind of like a musical event.
Neurons in one side of the brain
and another side of the brain,
I recognize them, color
or shape or something,
and if they vibrate together at about
40 cycles a second, if they create,
say the same note in step, that
synchrony is a cup of coffee,
and what's happening in the brain
is that there's a part of the brain
responsible for the
sense of smells, smell,
eh,
neurons that recognize the coffee aroma
or firing vigorously as they smell it.
Meanwhile, they're colored detectors
that happen to notice that it's a,
you know, a Red Mug,
eh,
shape detectors as part of the visual
system that are noticing the edge of the
[inaudible]
least.
What neurologists think is that it's
the simultaneous firing of all of those
that are looking at red
and at sensing the aroma.
It's the coincidence of their firing
that's telling them this is one thing.
This is not separate aromas and
colors and shapes. This is a coffee
they'd be singing together, Huh?
The
[inaudible]
a
so that is a cup of coffee and to
think we do it every morning before we
proceed,
we should think the New York
City LaGuardia composition
class or neurons where
my name's Harrison Hill and I'm
tasting, my name is Melanie Charles.
Danielle do visa boy.
My name is Jonathan Chew and
I am smell Jonathan Shoe.
Mr Smell did the arrangements
Robert Apostle conducted? No,
we say wait a second here because this
is interesting. Robert Apostle. Yes,
their conductor told
them what to do. Right.
But in your head when you think of a
cup of coffee, who's conducting you?
Huh?
And this is where we start getting into
the, the very mystical or even most,
most mysterious part of this is that who
is it that's paying attention? I mean,
because I mean, what is attention
hut? How can you control you?
I don't, I don't really even
know how to talk about this, but,
but there's something in you that
that is, uh, that is the signal.
Let's do coffee. Yeah. I mean
cause it's confusing that the,
what is it that brings one thing into
attention and not the other? Anyway,
I don't know. I'm a little
out of my depth here.
[inaudible]
somehow or other, whether we're looking
at ants, cities with the Internet,
wherever we look,
the shape and organization of the world
seems to emerge without an obvious plan.
And yet there it is.
And nowhere is this more mysterious and
more difficult to really comprehend than
in our own heads. Even right?
For scientists who work on
a day after day in the lab,
like this Guy Christoph Cock,
I'm a professor of neuroscience and
engineering at the California Institute of
Technology.
Chris stopcock is one of the
most celebrated neurologists
in the world and for
him and for many others, they have a hard
time getting rid of a model deep down,
which says somewhere in
there there's a conductor,
someone is organizing the
action. You made a mema.
There's a movie by Woody Allen called
everything you always wanted to know about
sex. I do, but the way of way to ask this
has great skits in it where he has um,
a, a couple is petting in the back of
it. Oh my God. Sydney, can't you wait?
Do you want to do it right
here in the parking lot?
You'd see inside the boys veins is
mission control, mission control.
You have this NASA type control room.
You have these big TV screen corresponding
to the output of the eyes to eyes
come in.
I used to brain over and you have
sort of all these white divest now for
technicians running around.
All systems go and we're going to get
an erection in the scene that says we're
trying to do. Yeah, exactly. Then
you have these, uh, you know,
all these Siemens that line up, they
all have these little parachutes.
It's a little long tails. Scared.
I don't want to go out there,
but I mean the point is, so this is
control of a metaphor that, that uh,
you know, we can all laugh about,
but a lot of people including scientists
have implicitly the ideas that meet as
a kissed off who sits inside
meetings. I can tell you,
most people can tell you it's,
it's exactly between my two eyes,
between here and here. And by the way,
this Christopher I assume would be saying,
okay sheet and this is in the movies.
It okay, she likes me.
Let's make the next one.
That's exactly what happens. Of course
in the Woody Allen movie. Exactly.
Show the points. Christopher [inaudible]
is that the woody Allen Model?
This idea that there's
an inner command center,
some conductor directing your
brain that thinks is wrong. Now.
Clearly there is no such person
inside my head for a lot, you know,
because who's sitting inside the head
of this little Christoph and then who's
sitting inside the head of the
person sitting inside my head.
You see the problem if Christopher's
thinking about a cup of coffee and he gets
the idea from an inner Christophe
who's thinking about a cup of coffee,
where did the inner
Christoph get the idea?
Maybe from an inner inner valve
that wouldn't really solve the pong.
We'll just push that one back.
[inaudible]
these are heavy problems.
I mean,
w what happens here is we're tiptoeing
up the hill here to the Mount Sinai of of
science.
Yeah, coffee cups in people
sitting into controls. Well,
these are kind of the smaller questions
on the foothills to the bigger one,
which is how does the mind reflect?
Why does someone know who an I is?
Why can you contemplate death? What
is this consciousness? That's the big,
if we can figure this out,
whatever circuit is responsible for
or circuits responsible for human
consciousness. Think of what we can do.
One day a doctor could walk
into a patient's hospital
room where the patient is
laying comatose and a
put a helmet on them.
It's a conscious o meter,
let's call it and measure how alive
they are or maybe even tickle a part of
their brain and make them back up. This
idea, by the way,
came from one of the most
famous scientists of the
20th century who worked very,
very closely with Christopher Koch. Um,
I'm talking about a man
named Francis Crick and I,
even if you know nothing
about science at all,
you've probably heard about the
discovery of the structure of DNA,
the DNA molecule by Watson and Crick.
This is that crick. He was a British guy.
He moved to southern California and at
some point he and Christopher coke met.
Now Coke was much, much younger,
decades younger than the older guy,
and yet they formed one of
the more magical partnerships,
a kind of Gilbert and Sullivan or
Rogers and Hammerstein of neuroscience.
And one of the ideas that crick
had was that there is a way,
they must be a way to figure out
what consciousness is all about.
They developed this notion,
there's no conscious entity inside my
head that serves the whole of conductor.
That's not to say that there may not be
places in the brain that act akin to a
conductor that sort of synchronized and
that called Nate the various parts of
the brain that find a penalty because
one of the remarkable phenomena of
conscience is everything's integrated.
When I look at you and you talk,
your voice comes out of
your mouth. When you move,
the most I perceive is attached
to your head, not in the brain.
All the things that analyze in
different parts of the brain.
So you need some sort of entity that
pulls all these different networks of the
brain together. Is there a place
in the brain that does that well?
So Francis Crick and I think
so. In fact, it was a, the,
the subject of his last
paper that he worked on,
on literally on the day he died,
there's this odd structure in the brain
called the to home close to means hidden
away. And it's a small area.
It's sort of an elongated sheet like
structure beneath the cerebral cortex.
You have two of them, one on
the left, one of the right.
And what's remarkable about it? Indeed,
this tractor receives input
from almost every cortical area,
the teams to be in an ideal position.
If you want to go to the metaphor of
synchronizing all the different activities
and making sure they're all
in some sort of lockstep.
So Francis and you have this idea and
he is very sick with cancer and he wants
to get this idea down is what's calling
it. Can you describe the scene there?
You first had this idea 10 years
ago and he talked about it in a,
in his book that he published in 94.
And then we never thought much
more about it over the last year.
We came back to this, um, this,
this sort of somewhat obscure structure.
So he was very, very interested in it.
And Yeah, he felt his, he felt his, um,
you know, as he felt his illness
coming on and getting stronger,
he was very adamant about trying
to finish up a manuscript.
So he literally worked
days and days and days.
There's this beautiful photograph of his
desk covered probably four inches deep,
just with paper pertaining
to the cloud storm.
And he worked a particular
over the last six weeks, um,
DNI to try to finish a manuscript or to
get it in reasonable shape for us to,
to publish. And so he
was on the day he died.
He was still writing the
scientist to the bitter end.
Is a kind of Mozart's requiem
quality to this? Yes, yes.
Yeah.
What was the last thing that
you and he said to each other?
Hello,
I'll see you on thirsty.
Or Friday I was supposed to visit
him in the hospital to work on this
manuscript. And was the
manuscript completed?
Uh, no, it's, I'm
currently working on that.
I'm editing it and then sending out
and abouts send it out to friends.
[inaudible]
because I feel a little bit exactly
like, um, the student of Mozart,
his names escapes and
who finished his requiem.
He had a student in finished spectrum
and now musicologist today at deciding
what is actually original Mozart and
what was finished in the style of Mozart.
And so I say,
which aware of this and you're stuffing
italics or something or something.
Like on the other end,
we publish 22 or 23 manuscript together
and the way we always work that he wrote
the first draft. It was so insistent
upon that. Then I bought, you know,
I edited and then he edit my edits
and we integrated. Unfortunately,
I can't do this anymore, so you know,
I just have to edit his draft
without the benefit of his feedback.
[inaudible]
Christopher [inaudible] is a professor
of neuroscience and engineering at the
California Institute of Technology.
His newest book is the
quest for consciousness.
There's more of radio lab
online@radiolab.org communicate with us
while you're there. Radio lab at Wny C.
Dot. Org is the address I'm Jad Abumrad
rapper Krav with Schneier's signing off.